the culture
this culture made it all the more
difficult if not
impossible for complainants to report
the harassment
one courageous woman after another step
forward
they stepped forward to say enough is
enough
they came forward in our investigation
to tell us
about their experiences the harassment
they suffered
at the hands of the governor in our
report
we've used their words and their words
so long silenced speak loudly
for themselves these brave women
stepped forward to speak truth to power
and in doing so they expressed faith
in the belief that although the governor
may be powerful the truth
is even more so this
is what lies at the heart of our
investigation and the findings in our
report
you will now take questions and the
questioning will be
directed by delaney kempner
this is a civil investigation
our work is concluded um and the
document is now public
um and the matter is civil in nature
and is not um does not have any criminal
consequences
my understanding
i will state that it's our understanding
that for the young woman whose
breast was groped at the albany police
department already has a report about
that
as for anything else as the attorney
general stated
all the information is fully documented
in the report and any prosecutors or
police departments can
look at the evidence and determine if
they want to take further action
um
there is no coordination between the
office of attorney general and the
assembly
the document is now public and will be
distributed
to the members of the assembly as well
as the leadership
[Music]
sure there's no penalty specifically
tied to this report
um the women can decide some of them can
decide themselves if they want to bring
a civil action
um the statute of limitations is
generally
three years under one federal statute in
the state law a little bit shorter under
another federal statute although
for hostile work environments as long as
one act
within the statute of limitations one
can go back to cover the entire hostile
work environment and in regards
harassment
do you think the governor is getting the
devastating nature of this report
i get what you're thinking about it's a
little prosecutor move forward on this
if you
the report speaks for itself and
right now i think we should all be
focused on the courageous
and bravery of the women who came
forward and all of us should be focused
on keeping women
safe believing women and allowing women
and that's exactly what this document
does
nbc you mentioned in your opening
remarks today
defending the credentials of your
investigators today
being personally bothered by the
governor's own remarks
in the past week or so that you can just
google their backgrounds and draw your
own conclusion
that this is a politically motivated
investigation there are attempts
to undermine and to politicize this
investigation
there were attacks on me as well as
members of the team
which i find defensive and our focus
again should be on the bravery and the
courage of these 11 women
and of the others who came forward some
patients were substantiated
they were corroborated and the team
before you miss clark and mr kim
are professionals who are widely
respected not only in new york but all
across this nation
and i support their work will defend
their work
and i believe these women
exactly you mentioned that it
corroborated a lot of people what the
weakest testimony was
there are some incidents that he
admitted to but had a different
interpretation of and there were other
things that he denied or said he didn't
recall
a little bit more about wnyc can you
speak a little bit more about
what that conversation that 11 hour
conversation was like the other way
summit um uh they said there were
certain things like he
admitted that he asked miss bennett
whether she had been involved with older
men
um he denied um touching the state
trooper although he said he might have
kissed her at an event
um and there were certain things that he
um
turned around and said that for example
the game assistant number one that he
did hug her repeatedly
but claims she was the one who initiated
the hugs
so it was a mixture of admitting to
certain things but putting a different
spin on them
and denying others
what are the next steps here you have
this report obviously a lot of
devastating information a lot of people
are going to have something so what
happens next
you're not referring to criminal charges
what are the next steps
that you would like to see perhaps maybe
the assembly tape or someone else
uh to have some other kind of punishment
or something else here
because right now it just seems like you
have this reporter and then it's out
there
for that we were tasked with the
responsibility of engaging in an
investigation
and we have concluded our investigation
um
and our work is done
and so as as it relates to next steps
that's entirely up to the governor and
or theater
and the general public but the work of
the office of the attorney general and
these
special deputies has concluded do you
think the governor could run for
reelection
that's a political question the work of
the office of the attorney general is
done
okay we're going to take two more
questions in here and then we're going
to go virtual
hi david from the new york
history of times a workplace like this
water running for governor waiting
for that person to serve as the leader
of the new york
times um a little report speaks myself
they substantiated and
issued findings that affect the governor
violating state and federal laws
nbc news
attorney general are you frustrated if
you can't move
criminally on these charges numerous
charges that you
and the investigators have said of
stable violence state and
federal law it's not an issue
and all throughout the process we've put
our heads down we've done our work
and at this point
thank you everybody if you have a
question please
click the raise hand button if you have
a question please click on great
hi attorney general uh a couple
questions and i apologize it's tough to
hear some of the the questions but
some of the things might piece here
the investigation into the governor's
book uh
book deal as well as the the staff
resources that are used on that
does that remain ongoing that's that's
the step from this is it still ongoing
and also
can you make some sort of formal
referral to prosecutors offices based on
uh on this report today or is that
something that they would have to pick
up the ball on
on their own um the investigation with
respect to
the book and whether or not public
resources are utilized is ongoing
separate and apart from this
investigation and with regard to
criminal jurisdiction criminal
jurisdiction usually is
uh conveyed upon the office of attorney
general usually we get a request under
the executive law and at this point in
time our work is concluded
um and we will not be engaging in any
criminal investigation with respect to
the conduct
of the governor of the state of new york
our second question is from josh gothi
from washington coast
josh your line zipper
gosh you have to unmute your line
you hear me now i'm sorry yeah we can
eat you josh he said hi attorney general
um
about 11 uh allegations here 11 uh
different victims you should find all 11
of the victims who came forward uh
to be uh credible and are you able to
find contemporaneous
uh notes or truths about
[Music]
we found all 11 women to be credible
there was corroboration to varying
degrees
um probably a breakdown at the
charlotte bennett talked to people and
texted
people um contemporaneously some of her
texts were practically in real time
regarding conversations with the
governor
as well the reports that she made to the
chief of staff and the special counsel
their contemporaneous notes are are
quite consistent with what she's
said to the press and what she told us
um the state trooper
um the the touching incidents um
the one where he touched her stomach was
witnessed by another
state trooper who confirmed it to us um
the kiss
of the governor kissed her once that was
confirmed to us by another state trooper
and there were other incidents where she
told people the time
other people that we spoke to did tell
people at the time that we confirmed
the people they spoke with or had
written documentation either text
messages or emails in which they
recounted things
contemporaneously so things things when
you see the report
everything is is documented things were
very well corroborated
the next question is from emma kinnery
from bloomberg news
emma your line is open
hello thank you um i was wondering
you said that your work is done but
there's still criminal matter
in place what would you what will happen
from there
so um i cannot speculate as to um
what will happen from external agencies
and or external legislative bodies that
is entirely
up to them but as far as the office of
attorney general
is uh is concerned our office
and our investigation has concluded we
will be issuing this report
as long along with evidence
to the general public
our next question is from brian barnelli
from the new york law journal
yes can you hear me okay yes um so
i know that there was mention of a
report to albany police department
regarding
the broken incident can you um specify
if that was made by the executive
chamber
or has uh the victim herself stepped
forward and given a report to all of
them
it's our understanding that the report
was made by the executive chamber
our last question is from rebecca lewis
from
city and state i thought your line is
open
hi attorney general um i just wanted uh
to ask
you know with this report out now he
said that you're not going to speculate
on whether the governor is going to
serve if he should run again
what do you want the public to take away
from this report
that these 11 women were in a hostile
and toxic work environment
and that we should believe women and
that what we have an obligation to do to
do is
in their workplace and what this
investigation revealed
the disturbing pattern of conduct
by the governor of the great state of
new york
and those who basically did not put in
place
any protocols or procedures to protect
these young women who believed in public
service
i believe women and i believe these 11
women
well thank you all for being here
[Music]
foreign
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the show my name is wayne dupri and
we
are we're live and we're back to live
uh glad to have you with us
as you have watched uh
part well uh our
version of what has happened uh
well actually let me introduce brian and
leah leah
and leah bella brian smith um
wow just to start to to start off
um i hope that everybody's doing well
today thank you for tuning in you know
you could be doing something else right
now but you know thank you
uh sometimes sometimes
we like uh especially like on the
weekend or whatnot if
something really is big and huge we'll
go live
for it uh january 6 whatever whatever
uh in this situation i was like
should we go live or should we not go
live and
when i saw this on all the chat see
what really gets me about this
even if it was live
the attorney general that many
people have been slamming uh
because you know they said she was
biased and whatnot
i was listening to her and how she
brought forth all this information
she didn't have to do that she it could
have been on
in the newspapers if she wanted to but
she went public with this
and not only was it not only was it
public
she looked hurt by the information
she she she looked like the information
74 000 pieces of evidence
evidence 74 000 and
i guess leah bryan
what shocked me was a state trooper yeah
yeah oh no for sure but
this is all part parcel this this is
like a flashback from james comey
and hillary clinton's emails yeah oh
after
all this boom boom boom boom boom as
we're watching live and we're like
holy hell she's going to prison and then
he says
oh and there's no there that no
no cr no criminal prosecutor in his
right mind
would pick this up for prosecution
that's literally what this one just said
ain't no criminal and i think it goes to
show you how terrible some of these
governors are political figures because
he denied
a lot of this they said or he didn't
recall it which we all know
from bill clinton he said the same thing
is yeah and you know i just wanna i
don't want to take away from the fact
that don't forget
he also sped up the deaths of what like
thousands of elderly people
and then covered it up so for anybody
out there saying
that he didn't do that this should prove
you that he probably did he's an
evil bad person yeah i mean if those
things i heard wayne was disgusting yeah
i mean i mean i
look i listen to these women
accounts and there's no way he can be
governor at five o'clock this afternoon
was beyond credible and and what what
joe biden did to tara reid
was unspeakable i'm glad you brought up
joe biden ladies and gentlemen
washington now you said you want the
investigation
to continue if the investigation
confirms the claims of the women
should he resign yes i think he probably
ended up being prosecuted too
investigation to continue if the
investigation confirms
the claims of the women should he resign
yes
i think he probably ended up being
prosecuted too
now he because he's in the fifth or
sixth stage of dementia
but that's why we have it on video okay
he saved the video
great thank god for he said that he
should
and not only that i want y'all to read
this
andrew cuomo tweeted this out september
24th the allegations of sexual assault
against judge kavanaugh are disturbing
and deeply concerning we owe it to the
american people to
believe survivors i call on the senate
to postpone any vote until these
allegations
are fully investigated that's
andrew cuomo wow about judge kavanaugh
so let me ask you this what does the
left do with this at this point like
does he go on chris como tonight with
his giant q-tip and they say it was
mostly peaceful sexual harassment and it
was mostly
peaceful sexual harassment nothing to
see here no i mean i
don't try to spin this and twist it i
don't think it would be
you know that would be so awful to go on
his brother's show oh that's what they
do
you're right but it's just so obvious
it'd be cringe-worthy wouldn't it
and right and and i'm also surprised
if chris goes on tonight
you're right wayne he would have to not
he would have to be off
maybe he'll say he got covered again
maybe i don't know
show up naked in the the woods
fall too far from the tree remember his
naked yoga
i'll tell you he's yeah yeah
um for for those of you that
uh for those let's see uh let's see
i me let me do it like this okay uh
oh look the light the lights came on
because you usually well i didn't know
we were going on like that so
okay um let me let me catch up everybody
on what has happened uh the attorney
general lita
ford wasn't afforded i was getting
caller
leader james but that's not her name um
the attorney general okay i'm sorry uh
she went pub i mean
i i mean i get look i gotta give the
woman credit i do i do
she said that her office was targeted
after she started this investigation oh
yeah she said that
the governor's office went i mean
basically tried to put the hammer down
on her for her not to investigate this
stuff
and i was like wow does she not work for
the governor i mean is she appointed by
the governor or is that another no
okay so that's different than the
federal at the federal level where the
president
appoints the attorney general yeah so at
the state level
they vote she she technically doesn't
work for the governor
right right technically but you know how
some of these things go they protect me
yeah yeah but um this is this is her uh
coming out the independent investigation
has concluded
that governor andrew cuomo sexually
harassed multiple women
and in doing so violated federal and
state law
specifically the investigation found
that
governor andrew cuomo sexually harassed
current
and former new york state employees by
engaging in unwelcome
and non-consensual touching and making
numerous offensive comments
of a suggestive and sexual nature
that created a hostile work environment
for women
you know you notice how she kept saying
his name so that nobody gets it mixed up
yeah
yeah like no andrew cuomo andrew cuomo
andrew right cuomo as a matter of fact
this investigation has revealed conduct
that corrodes
the very fabric and character of our
state government
and shines light on injustice
that can be present at the highest
levels of government
but none of this none of this would have
been
illuminated if not for the heroic
women who came forward
and i am inspired by all the brave women
who came forward
but more importantly i believe them
sorry about that but um yeah how many
how many women
for her honey it seems like it's 17
like 70. i think 17 came forward but
there were like
over like 2 000 instances
there were many instances well this
should be a class action lawsuit
again you know get together make it
happen there was one thing that she did
say i found
interesting is that if somebody is
currently
working there and it was like an olive
branch if you're currently working there
and you're watching and waiting to
pre-show
heads up you can get involved in this
and the fact that statute limitations
won't apply
because they'll look at your instinct
right now and be allowed
to go back to every single instance in
the past
i mean that's what should be focused on
right now find something right now going
on
or something recent and go go go delve
back into the past
so and i don't think the left really
cares because they don't really need him
i mean they fought
the trump and him fought so he was a
good mouthpiece
against trump but really do they need
him anymore he's kind of like dead
weight right so they're probably all
going to turn on him yeah
well for yes and no because
for somebody who has done this and been
able to get away with it and use the
office to bully
and and
everybody you know you know how
democrats have been talking about uh
walking trump and putting the cuffs on
trump and stuff
you gotta look you gotta have a grand
jury for this one
i mean you gotta have a new york grand
and allow these witnesses to talk
be and and and honestly give some time
to the new york government i know i know
i know we've said on this show many
times rich people
and uh rich people get off and stuff
like that but
uh i i mean honestly i really don't see
i mean if he's still governor right now
i'm i'm shocked
yes yeah i know i know i know but
yes that's that's good
so his his uh his seat isn't up until
24.
he said he was in or is it four years as
governor or six
i thought okay so he was he was in the
incumbent in 2018
so he's not up till 24. are people
assuming he's going to stop i think he's
so air this guy is
so arrogant there's no way he steps down
i just i can't see it okay i don't think
he does either
okay then the people on the people at
the top
in new york is on trial right now yeah
yeah sure yes i agree those people
and their future okay their future seats
because honestly this this right here
about cuomo this piece this
today could decide what happens
in new york over the next few years
crime might go up governor get away with
his stuff
crime goes up because nobody gives away
nobody gives a crap now i mean you know
i mean you got a governor that is feel
feeling down troopers uh putting his
hand in trooper's stuff
grabbing them yeah the first victim was
like he pulled me close and then he ran
his hand
right up my blouse and he pulled me so
close that people couldn't see it so he
could rub his
so he can run it i was like holy break
down as to what had happened
and they were the ones that reported the
conduct to attorneys in the executive
chamber
the governor also several times
inappropriately touched
a state trooper assigned to the unit to
protect the governor
in an elevator while standing behind the
trooper he ran his finger
from her neck down her spine and said
hey you another time she was standing
holding the door
open for the governor as he passed he
took his open hand
and ran it across her stomach from her
belly button
to where she the hip where she keeps her
gun
she told us that she felt completely
violated
to have the governor touch her as she
put it between her chest and her
privates
the governor also inappropriately
touched women who were attending
work-related events at which the
governor made remarks
at one event in september 2019 while
having his picture taken with an
employee of a state entity
the governor grabbed this young woman's
butt
at another event in may of 2017
the governor pressed and ran his fingers
across the chest of a woman
while reading the name of her company
whose logo was on her chest
the governor also engaged in a
widespread pattern of subjecting women
to unwanted hugs and kisses and touching
them in ways that made them
uncomfortable
conduct you know
in not just that but you also listen to
what she said later when she said um
or the other guy said
he was talking to a 20 year old
and he said i could date someone as
young as 22.
and but those that are in their late
20s is too old for me
and then and then he said because i
listen to this intently and then he
and then she said somebody who had
already gone through sexual harassment
he asked her how he she felt isn't that
sick but i mean basically trying to
see how she would feel if he would do
something like that to her
sec i was like oh wow well you guys you
guys remember what happened to that
other democrat that uh got
got a photo take a photo op of touching
uh uh a sleeping girl's breasts
old al franken had to quit yeah
yeah yeah yeah people i guess
check marks on twitter are asking him to
uh resign but i want to tell you how
unfazed he is about this two hours ago
because you knew
he he knew that this was coming out two
hours ago
he tweeted i'm honored to declare august
3rd
tony bennett day in new york i mean as
if nothing even happened
happy birthday tony bennett it's your
95th birthday
yeah it's like he he's literally wishing
tony bennett a happy birthday
as he's getting accused of sexual
harassing you're not accused but
actually this is a it's a shame he's
unfaith he lives in a whole different
world
as do most politicians i just hope i
just hope i don't know
but i've never seen anything like that
before like that
i've seen like the clinton thing i saw
that one that was for the president
united states
but i really haven't seen a democratic
attorney general that was supposed to be
biased who could
possibly still be biased i can't call
her bias now because of what she did to
cromwell
i can't run
it would look too opportunistic at this
point but
right now
yeah but why why didn't she maybe she
couldn't but i'm perplexed and i know a
lot of people in the chat are perplexed
about it too but
where are the criminal charges i agree
he needs to resign be arrested and then
like you said prosecuted
nice if they lose the prosecution
the fact that i mean you're going to do
this to trump
you're going to purp walk trump like
we're talking now right
you might as well do it to someone who
deserves to be perp-walked
i agree i mean we've got video of him
being
disgustingly creepy when it comes to
women
yeah um
okay so that's why that's why we went a
little bit early
we wanted uh again i was like
what's going on again but but the ag
said that she's not going to bring
charges right she
she said that i guess i guess the scope
of what she was supposed to do
and i don't know again for her own
political
advancement it's like yeah it's like
comey did the same thing comey did the
same thing this is what we found
there it is we're done right who
initiated it was it
it wasn't promo no no no it might have
been her might have been the ag
so if aj did it then she's leaving it up
to the top which is a shame because she
can actually
do it so that makes me feel like she's
doing this for political advances only
because remember she ran on the fact
i hate trump that's what she ran on
right so you know
anything that she can do to to advance
politically i think she's going to do
so not real impressed with her i get it
that she put on a good somber act there
but yeah
yeah i mean and thinking about a little
bit more you know
yeah but in in watching her i was
i was i
applaud what she did because
i'm glad she took it serious you're
right he's the tougher guy
cuomo is a tough guy trombo
um sticks his nose in the air and looks
down on
us paupers and right he's a little bit
different than fredo
yeah yeah yeah and for for her to sit up
there
and she she took decided to women
even even this guy um it was a culture
where you could not say no to the
governor
and if you and if you upset him or his
him or his senior staff you will be
written off
cast aside or worse but at the same time
the witnesses described a culture that
normalized
and overlooked everyday flirtations
physical and intimacy and inappropriate
comments by the governor
it wasn't just him it was a culture
and the culture goes its culture starts
from the top and
and it moves throughout i've been
involved in a lot of different political
camps if you will that are local but but
still part of
a matter of fact one happened to me i'm
not saying it was like this
but i was vying for a top position in
the field here
in all of cincinnati to head things up
for a campaign
and uh the most qualified came with
recommendations from other officials and
and everything else
and and they told me they told me to my
face said brian
we need a young girl
i said you'd say what he said yeah brian
we we just
we just need a young girl for this area
we think that that's the best
i said a girl yeah yeah we got this girl
she said she's in college and uh
we're gonna bring her on board what well
i can tell you
i was livid andrew cuomo reminded me of
my old boss who was also from new york
in fact i think close to his town and he
always sexual harassed
everybody in the office so i can tell
you he's not the only politician that's
doing this
i don't know right right i wish that
more people would
would stand up and say something and not
even about sexual harassment let me just
take a second and say
i know there's people out there that
know things that are illegally going on
in the democrat party or in whatever
party
you need to speak up about it you need
to be a whistleblower for it i
wish that more people did that i think
we'd have the best transparency ever in
this country
if we did more things like this to
actually see people be
called out and prosecuted hopefully he's
prosecuted but
so i'll put out an olive branch anybody
that works for mike dewine
yeah you come on the show we will
interview you
all day long or wolf or tom what is his
name tom wolf
is that my governor's name
yeah whoa in my head
and then on top of this okay go ahead
sorry i said
was just going to say you had mentioned
the pentagon's on lockdown too pentagon
is on lockdown from what i heard uh
a couple of people have been injured uh
i really don't know that too much more
about it but yes the pentagon
was on is was on lockdown was there an
active shooter
yeah yeah yeah yeah active shooter yeah
how was that possible and we've talked
about this before
on on not necessarily military
installations but including them
government installations military
installations how is it possible that we
have
these kind of incidents it says here the
lockdown happened
after alleged shooting occurred near a
platform by the facilities pentagon
metro station
i know what that is according to the
police all the entrances of the pentagon
have been secured
the arlington fire department is there
and there are multiple people down
at the side of the shooting but still
wouldn't comment if the shooting
scene is still active so there are
multiple people shot
that that that platform
is where people are dropped off
to work oh really at
the pentagon yeah when you leave the
pentagon
unless you are like top dog or something
like that
they bust you in and then they bust you
out so then let me ask you a question
do you think the people that got shot
then would might be people that work in
the pentagon
yes for sure or or or it could be
um tourists that that
are also there to
it's where those is where that uh
it's not a graveyard um it's like a
memorial center of something the
memorial
center's over there right okay and
people take the bus over there to the
memorial center
and then they take their photos and yeah
but it stops
right i it's there's a lot of buses that
go in and out of that thing so wow
and i know i know exactly where that is
and i think that this will end up being
a story just real quick to let you know
i guess there's some type of vet
some ships have lost control of their
navigation
in the seas as if someone hacked them
can you imagine
somebody is playing a game boy
major game and
before probably probably before the end
of next year
there's going to be a major major outage
everywhere and my speculation this is so
big and
and the ones that we've had recently
yeah they they were asking a couple
million here
it was just a group of hackers my
personal opinion that
these hackings are so big that there
absolutely is a government a government
behind this is it absolutely it could be
china
i mean you know like i said it's my
hunch
yeah that's my vet they born hackers so
my mypillar.com ladies and gentlemen if
you're watching the show
if this is your first time watching the
show we want to let you know there
is uh a huge um
push for mypillar.com they
have a lot of uh
products that can help you start your
day
in a way that is supposed to be
okay you aren't supposed to wake up
cranky you aren't supposed to wake up
i am not a morning person you aren't
supposed to wake up like that's the
truth
you i and you know what and i never
understood that honest
i'm not a morning person really get your
tail up and go to work
but um uh wayne's a morning person i can
i can he's texting me at eight am i'm
snoring like a baby
hey hold on hold on he's like eight a.m
in the morning
eight a.m the morning person that
everybody get up my dad i know i know
right not good
i sleep till like 10. you gotta get
around four or five
gym by 4 30. yeah yeah
that's just that i wouldn't be able to
function i have to have at least 12
hours sleep but what i want you guys to
do is wayne brought up a good point
about not waking up cranky taking care
of yourself
just to piggyback off that listen who
came to you this week stressed out who
came to you and said look i just can't
take it my employer's gonna fire me if i
don't get this vaccine
or i'm so sick and tired of seeing the
left destroy this country or
maybe they're having problems at home or
health problems if you have a person
like that you wouldn't believe
what honestly just a small gift would do
for them just get them a towel set and
say here you know what pamper yourself
uh over the weekend or here you know
what i got you a nice set of sheets
just put them on enjoy or here's a nice
pillow i know you haven't been sleeping
well or you and your husband have been
arguing lately
here's two pillows for you guys maybe
they're nurses and they're working
really hard right now get them slippers
anything like that yeah or may maybe
you've got you've got nurses who
say they're working hard and said
they're just doing tick-tock dances
you can do a ticket right you know
they're getting tired of the tick-tock
that they're doing over there in
california uh but no
find somebody you love who has been
negative this week and change their day
with your code word wayne deborah said
she orders the towels yesterday
nice thank you
what is so funny what did i say
that's why sorry i said you cranky
before noon on weekends
what's that mean i don't know okay so
um basically basically you go
toward uh the the radio
the radio listener specials okay radio
listen especially you click on it
and they have uh awesome
special great work six piece sales at
39.99
thousand you know that's like 65
off yeah the towels are huge hold on
let's show them this come on come on
come on come on
the whole six-speed towel set is 109
you get it for 39.99
and you can pick and you can actually
pick whatever colors that you want
but it's just not the towels ladies and
gentlemen and
we're going to get to some more news in
just a second but they have the juice
giza dream sheets they also have
these slippers i have on my slippers
right now uh
they they also have the my pillow
premiums which
can get soft or firm whatever uh
leah has um uh talked about the bobble
pillow cases about uh yeah love story
she loves her pillow and it's perfect
for kids because their heads are
their heads are so tiny for these big my
pillows these are the perfect size
pillows for them to sleep on
she has the middle one um yeah and she
loves it but you can get
the story about i think it's uh mary and
joseph you can get one about noah's ark
and there's a lot of people in the chat
that said they did just get them justin
in the chat said he's going to buy his
towel set on friday wayne so he's going
to use your code on friday when he gets
paid
now uh this and
ryan you got the mattress topper a while
back didn't you yeah you got the
mattress topper i was about to say that
mattress topper comes with uh two free
pillows it's phenomenal
if you've got a mattress and you're not
ready to change it out but you hate it
or you don't like it or you got waking
up like we said not in a good mood
throw that mattress topper on there and
a couple of free pillows and i'll tell
you what
it's like being at a five-star resort it
rejuvenates your mattress to being
like a really nice thing to sleep on
uh if you want to take a step further
you can go ahead and get the whole kit
and caboodle get you a new mattress
i'm just saying and and also
before before we before we roll out uh
they have one inch two inch and three
inch of the mattress topper
uh yeah one inch two inch they
have all of the sizes okay they have
all of the sizes
rv and i mean extra king
you listen if you're sure get the
two-inch i don't know i have to use a
foot stool i've got a three-inch i have
to use a footstool to get into bed
that's how thick they are i am getting a
couple of these for my daughters
who are getting ready to go to college
so if you have kids that are in college
that are sleeping on those prison
mattresses then
you give them this and you again you get
two
free pillows so it's almost like a two
in one but uh
i know somebody messaged me and asked
about how their uh
like sleepwear is i haven't tried it yet
so i will order some
right and i'll let you know and one more
thing brian uh
brian brian talked about the the
the mattress and the adjustable base set
well
here's the thing they have a foam
mattress
okay and they also have the coil
all of these are patented for
created by my pillow okay i
i decided i went back and forth i looked
a lot of different reviews
and i decided to go with the foam
mattress i've never had one before
the reviews made me a little bit nervous
but i'm gonna tell you right now
i i'm no secret i weigh about 205 pounds
and they said for a man my size you
shouldn't do the foam mattress because
you're just too heavy for it now y'all
go to hell
it's crazy i love it
it's awesome that's awesome yeah yeah i
mean i'm not
i'm not that championship wing either
but i tell you what i'm
i'm i i love my phone mattress okay so
just remember you go there use codename
wayne
everything we find okay um
a lot of thing like this week i wanted
to touch on
things that we can't talk about
yesterday
it was the vaccine today
uh it's about and and you don't see
too much about it right now the media's
not talking about it
but it's still a huge problem and that's
what's happening down there
at the border and what the gems are
trying to do for
uh these uh these dreamers
or even illegal
well we call them illegal aliens they
they want them called
undocumented immigrants you do your
thing okay
you do your thing you don't like the
word illegal
in any facet you don't you don't illegal
crime illegal whatever you don't like
the word illegal that's fine
we're going to call them illegal aliens
senator journey
joni erst came out and said there should
be no pathway of citizenship
for law breakers that is the most
common sense sentence that anyone can
say
regarding individuals that know that
they are he
that they are here illegally they know
they're here
here illegally and they're pushing
to jump in front of individuals that
came here
and are trying to become legal
citizens the right way they're trying to
jump the line
just because maybe they think that they
can help their legal prayer and their
parents are still illegal
that's the thing their parents are still
illegal they are illegal
and joe biden has called them uh well
they're american citizens but you're not
you're not american citizens
yeah i'm just trying to think about what
other country in the world
has such a jacked up system as we have
right now i mean this is insanity for
government uh
for politicians to be allowed to skirt
the law
or be allowed to manipulate and twist
and for anybody that follows alan west a
phenomenal patriot
uh that served served for our great
military
alan west over the weekend post up
pictures of
texas and uh overpass in texas
where there looked to be thousands uh
oh yeah illegals that were arrested uh
being held
detained i mean this this is not
acceptable
this is not how we survive as a nation
if you want to help and for those out
there bleeding hard i understand
my heart breaks for these these folks
too my heart breaks for the children
that that have these bastard parents
that just throw their kids
over the fence because i've got kids i
would never do such a such a heinous
thing and my heart breaks for him but
what we should be doing
helping them where they're at so they
want to stay where they're at
instead of doing some screwed up uh
executive order obama stuff and say ah
daca
ah whatever bring them my question is
what's the incentive then to come in
legally
if you can come in illegally
quicker right right not only that but if
you're okay with coming to this country
illegally then what else are you willing
to do that's illegal
because it sounds to me like you're okay
with breaking the law
so then you're going to come into a
country and then you're going to be able
to justify
breaking lawnmower it's okay if i rape
that girl that's illegal but hey
it's breaking the law and i already
broke the law once by coming in
i mean we've seen it we know what has
happened in california
we know people that have died at the
arms of illegal immigrants
right and we're seeing right now that
these illegals and
uh some of the new what they call them
first generations over here that have
come over here
the welfare though i mean they're on
welfare like
almost all of them i think it's a high
above 75 percent get some kind of
government assistance
they're not even trying right they're
not even trying well
okay i don't want to say that the wrong
way but
a lot of people aren't even trying to
work
they hear that they that you get these
benefits
especially in california you get these
benefits you get a driver's license
you get housing you get this and that
and you really don't have it
and then the state's going to pay you
something and
if you get your children in at the right
time you get it registered and then you
got illegal children
already in school right and they're
doing it for a purpose ladies and
gentlemen the
the purpose is you can't take children
out of school
that's how we get paid you can't take
these little children out of school
that's
so that's so inhumane
or you know you know and and that's how
they
uh that's how they pull on these
heartstrings but
i just wish i just wish i'm sorry i just
wish that we
had some people just a couple
beyond this show that would say
get that illegal child out of school and
get them right or send them back that's
just the way it is
now we love you but we got to enfor
we have to invoke we have to enforce a
couple things
and yo you aren't doing it the right way
now
i can penalize you right now i can
penalize you a couple thousand dollars a
day
maybe that'll wake you up oh a couple
a couple thousand won't work i can
penalize your ten thousand dollars a day
i'm the government i can finish i can
penalize you if you don't want to do it
the right way
and then you know then they go back hey
um
julio you got to get your children out
of school and these kids in l.a unified
are getting three meals a day they're
getting fed on the weekends they're
getting fed during the week
i mean they're literally housing
children in la unified
well you have to keep in mind too that i
understand that a lot of people will use
the that oh yeah they're bringing them
in so that way they get more voters
but there's another reason why they're
bringing them in for this ensures them
that at some point they're going to get
to an universal
income this is to help the country get
to a universal income because they know
they'll accept it like you said through
welfare
dependent on the government and then
also school indoctrination
most children that are illegal they
don't have people to stand up for them
and say wait no that's not what happened
in america
they don't know any better so whatever
they're taught they're not going to
question
so this ensures universal income
dependent on government
and school indoctrination because no one
will question it because they think it's
the truth
because they don't know any better it's
a perfect setup
right and the crying shame and speaking
about the
the founding of america the crying shame
is that i never knew who
uh locke or montesquieu was and for
those of you who've never heard those
two words before
look them up our founding fathers knew
their philosophies
so very very very well and and if we
want to save this country we need to
reteach our children
what made america the greatest nation in
the world
and that was by the philosophers of loch
and montesquiou
who were god-fearing men and and our
founding fathers even said without
moral uh moral guard rails
this just won't work democracy can't
work we don't have morality
democracy don't work and now we're
seeing this thing fall apart right and
you have to realize that when you come
over here illegally
uh those that don't want to break the
law because they do want to be here
they're going to obey whatever you say
so they're not like i said they're not
listening right they're not going to
question anything
they're going to take the government
handle help and they're going to keep
their head down
and they're not going to speak up
they're very sheep-like they're very
quiet because they don't want to get
kicked back out that makes a perfect
country to control
yeah that's true and if you look at the
attorney general
merrick garland he he's saying he's
going to sue
uh uh greg abbott in texas we dodge a
bullet with him
over there yeah right bro imagine being
on supreme court for a little while
i can't i that is scary
he calls it now garland caused
immigration order dangerous and unlawful
now the governor signed it
the governor signed it so i mean well
it might not have been pushed through
the legislation to become a law but
usually if the governor signed certain
things
i mean the democrats are pushing through
these mandates
aren't those unlawful arrests in public
health
yeah a risk the public yeah i thought
bringing them over here with kobe's a
risk to public health
i don't that's what i don't understand
i'm so confused on if covets this bad
and i know that you guys have heard this
over and over again
but that's my honest question i'd like
to hear you guys point of view on that
if covet is that bad that we are now
asking for vaccination to get into gyms
and restaurants because they just
changed that new york city i'm sure
wayne will be bringing that up later
but yet they're still allowed over our
border could someone please explain that
to me
how this is happening and this should be
a health crisis on the border
phrase oh yeah yeah this is this is the
beginning of another pandemic and i
i say it facetiously folks but but but
not really but i mean if
if covid was the pandemic that there was
supposed to be
well hell's bells we got the start of
another one right here on the border
yeah they all bring it in here and they
know
and and and like y'all are saying they
ask these people have they taken it
and they say no and then they said okay
well
get on the bus and we'll drop you in the
communities and there you go republicans
communities mostly just thrown to santos
florida
there's a lot of them being dropped in
southern california
i don't know what the rules in florida
are but let me tell you
the welfare system in the state of
california
is the largest thing that has to be out
the largest welfare program out there
it's unbelievable
if you're homeless and you go to the
welfare system they'll give you
a um i was going to say a condo not a
condo what are the no-tell motel rooms
they'll give you a no-till motel
right on for you for 30 days right for
30 days and they'll pay for it for free
they'll give you food they'll give you
cash aid they'll get you
bus passes whatever you need you're
illegal
right you renew that legal or illegal
doesn't matter you just renew that you
don't have to show any id
you just say i'm here and this is what i
got and you renew that every 30 days
and in three months then you gotta wait
30 days to come back
and it's it's this sick revolving
cycle that they get these people caught
up in
question what if we do hands across
america but go to the border and i'll
hold hands and don't let anybody come in
i mean is that is that something we
could all do we used to make jokes about
it
we um uh another joke was
built build a build a hill
a high enough hill for
for about 25 miles left east
to west build a hill then
allow americans to just stand on the
hill with
snipers paintball guns paintball guns
yeah come on over
a red rover red rover i dare you to come
over
run over
[Laughter]
yeah you pink blue red yellow
yeah got it load it up
but uh yeah uh merrick garland yes
merrick garland
um we are happy that we dodged him for
uh the the uh supreme court but we're
because we're seeing what he's doing
with the uh under the attorney general
and um don't give turtle a pass on this
one
it was because of turtle but he doesn't
get it
he's done so many criminal things that
he's married to china
yeah literally literally literally
um real quick uh if
uh one um one of our new sponsors is
called
never quit water uh i had i have the
video
on my timeline on my um twitter timeline
but uh it is a new set well it's a new
system
we're going to have the creator on on
thursday but the system
cleans foods cleans uh
vegetables cleans counters cleans
a whole lot of uh uh
products within the home better
than any filtration system that i've
ever seen
it also helps your body your body is
more than 75
water so what kind of water are you guys
putting into your body that's going to
affect your health
because not all waters are created equal
you know there's tap water bottled water
reverse osmosis that can have dead water
and acidic water in it
you need to be drinking living water uh
this water is actually living water it's
alive with antioxidants electrolytes
it's super hydrating um and honestly
you gotta see if you haven't yet watched
on wayne's video
the washing of the chemicals off the
tomatoes it literally removes the
chemicals off the tomatoes
right now there's seven different uh
settings on there you can use one for
beauty one for clean water one for maybe
you want to go a little bit more
alkaline
i know that that's why i'm getting it
because i want to be able to drink
the alkaline water it helps you keep the
acid out of you which
lowers your rates of cancer so that's
important
but check it out you can get one for
christmas and there's no credit checks
you can do a monthly payment
yep you can get everyone
is approved there is no credit check
and if you are overseas if you are
overseas
they have ways of shipping this to you
and you get it within a couple days it
it is a
a product that you attach to where it's
portable too
um but you attach it to uh whatever
whatever you're using bath uh sink
uh whatever your attachment to your
hotel if your hotel's disgusting
i can tell you my husband went to a
hotel in north carolina a few weeks ago
and they shut down the entire county
because there was
uh someone got e coli from the water and
they couldn't use the water this would
have been a perfect time to be able to
use the never quit water
wow yeah wow that's horrible yeah they
couldn't even shower they had
they the uh woman said stand up in the
bathtub and wash yourself down with a
washcloth
keep your eyes nose and mouth closed
i i'd wash with the military
if it can happen in a small town north
carolina it can happen where you
you are don't drink tap water get one of
these my question is i'd like to know
uh what it does uh with fluoridated
water
good question that'll write it down for
on thursday
great question great question visit
neverquitwater.com to receive more
information
you can finance this equipment everyone
is approved
right exactly take a look and see what
they do to the sweet potato on
neverquitwater.com
you'll see the difference it's crazy now
um
this is interesting this one
the uh what's his name um
michael michael mccall who's out of
texas
shared new findings of the house foreign
affairs committee republicans probe into
the
possible origins of covert 19 on monday
and he accused the ccp of engaging in
the greatest cover-up
in amer in in human history
um during during his uh during his
appearance on american news room laid
out a number of key points
from the report and asserted that the
ccp likely
very concerned by its finding
well ccp is likely very concerned about
that surely they were playing with fire
they genetically manipulated uh
at the lab this gain of function that
was taking place
that's what many people are seeing now
actually
or they're realizing right now is that
china
uh that china manipulated a certain uh
uh thing that they were doing
and it got it right it got out and
i'm look i'm not saying that we are any
better
but sarin gas was accidentally
created we we accidentally created sarin
gas
the people that created it said we wish
that we never created
staring gas it was an accident
if you ever see what sharing gas does to
you oh yeah it's
terrible it's bad it's terrible
here's the one the um the atomic bomb
oppenheimer yeah yeah he wept
he went yeah he was like he
was sorry that he had a hand
because the because the government
pushed him
those people pushed him to get the atom
bomb created and after he saw
just a just a sample it wasn't even put
it wasn't even dropped down on hiroshima
and nagasaki
when he saw what it did to the land
and what he did to he was like
the guy who invented dynamite regretted
it and he won the nobel peace prize for
it
yeah and he was depressed about it but
with china though
china's not sorry they didn't they're
not coming out saying sorry they're not
crying
they saying nothing they created this
thing
most of us understand this it's not
misinformation
but there's really no way to stop it
seriously well the sad part was it could
have been stopped
because in september of 2019
you can see on google maps from china
this is not a joke you can look it up
and see that the hospitals and wuhan
were overwhelmed
and google has a memory don't forget
anything you do on the internet
always has a footprint and they went
back and saw what they were googling i
guess you could say over in china and it
was all the symptoms of kovid
back in september and then they had the
war games come and just spread it across
the world
uh people from the war games actually
said wuhan looked like a ghost town they
also complained of symptoms of coven 19
like related illness
this is this was going on in september
they should have locked their borders
then they should have never had the war
games they knew about it
that's the issue they didn't want to
come out they were hoping that it would
just go away
or if it was spread well no big deals
you know we don't want to be blamed for
it
this is the irresponsibility of the ccp
and it will never stop
they the labs are still open they're
still working there
yeah i mean this is what we have to do
something about the ccp and
unfortunately i don't see that happening
no barack obama and uh dr fauci funded
helped to fund the ccp helped to fund
the gain of function
um my personal opinion probably not too
far off
is that the ccp found a way to
to get this out on purpose you know with
with military members getting it with
chinese getting and still flooding
that was the thing about italy china
literally owns italy
italy's economy almost crashed years
back and it's
really really not really recovered but
but china is starting to buy
up all kinds of stuff in italy and
there's a lot of chinese people who live
there
and so after this happened the reason
why uh italy got it so bad
because all the chinese were going back
to italy with it
spreading it throughout the whole
country well it's interesting you know
italy you might as well now you're in
all of europe
well it's interesting you brought up
italy because i just saw a report come
out of italy and i will cite that in
it for you guys tomorrow i'll find it
but they said a woman complained of
boils
on her and a sore throat in italy and
they took some of her uh i guess fluid
from her boils and sent it off for
testing
and it came back positive for covid but
they just found out like
just this year so she's the first
positive case ever known to man
and they can't find her there was no
name listed it was just a number the
doctor that actually
uh helped her has since died so no one
knows her name
they can't find her but they're trying
to track her she's like 25 years old
with dark hair
in italy who complained of covet-like
symptoms in september or october
with boils and a sore throat and they're
thinking she may be
patient number one that could give us an
answer to all of this
and they're looking for her right now
wow
yeah wow um
let me s uh
i've said on this show like i watched
i love i love documentaries i do i i
love documentaries
um especially when they are uh
built on historical facts
um and
i love learning okay i'll say i love
learning
in this case i was watching a
documentary about
what happened down in jonestown uh
yeah they had seen a couple sent a
couple of those
yeah yeah they they had video of jim
jones
throughout the whole thing uh when he
started his uh
his his thing in california and and
and and and all that stuff well wayne
where are you going with this um
there were some there was a
senator i think it was a senator that
went down democrat
democrat senator that that went down to
try to find out
what was going on at jonestown because
some of the family members in california
said look they're doing stuff down there
you know they're keeping people against
the will and okay so
senator and his entourage went down to
jonestown in guyana
some of it uh it turned out some of them
didn't make it out
and after they were shot up on the
tarmac
um jim jones did the coulee
killer thing and over 900 people
were killed yes there were some
survivors
i think his son made it out didn't it
both hunts
both sons right right they're here to
tell
the tale from the dark side yeah because
it looked crazy i saw videos wow
what a cult over 900 people
were killed babies uh young kids
and men and women but in this case
democrat representative right now jackie
speier i did not know
she went down to jonestown with rock
she was shot up to about five times
damn trying to board the airplane right
she tried to board an airplane she was
shot
five times she was left
for dead i feel
bad for her and i think and and putting
aside politics
i applaud that she
survived and tried to find i mean and
tried to uh
um expose what was happening down there
and everything like god bless you
exactly god bless you there but that's
where it stops because what she did now
is she is trying to associate
yeah i said i have to say this she's
trying to associate
donald trump with jim jones
and one of the great things about being
shown on cnn international
is that i hear from viewers who observe
american political dysfunction
from an outsider's point of view these
citizens in other countries sometimes
email me and say you know why doesn't
the american media
just call out trump for what he is call
trump fandom for what it is
sometimes they use the word cult
i know that's a sensitive word it
doesn't come up a lot in american news
coverage
so i wanted to put it to an expert an
unfortunate expert
congresswoman jackie spear started out
her career in politics uh
working for a lawmaker she was on a
fact-finding mission to jonestown
she sadly knows firsthand about the
weight of that word
cult she was able to escape with her
life others
were not able to that day so i wanted to
hear her thoughts
about the comparison uh the notion of
the cult of trump
um especially in the light of january 6
and the mass delusion that led people to
a riot of lies on capitol hill
when i brought this up with her she did
not mince words
there's no question that you could
compare
jim jones as a charismatic leader
who would bring his congregation
together
force them to do things that were
illegal
and then took 900 of them into the
jungles of guyana
where over the course of time he then
convinced them
that they should die i've never been
able to say they committed suicide
because i don't think they were in
control
okay now before before i let my co-host
talk about this
the the the people that went down to
guyana
they didn't do something illegally
they were church-going people that just
wanted
to start a fresh anew it wasn't illegal
to do that
uh so that is misinformation
number two uh with
with her comparing trump to jim jones
as a cult like type thing jim jones
jim jones himself in his own words
is nothing like what trump
is doing or tried to do for
america jim jones wanted socialism came
out of his mouth
it came out of his mouth he wanted
socialism he also
did a whole now he did a lot of things
illegally
okay and
he did you know the shooting and whatnot
not even close go
okay so here's an outsider's point of
view like uh little brian seltzer says
obviously he did this to try to get his
ratings up because his ratings are
tanked just one question if jim jones
and trump are the same
then why aren't all trump followers
taking the vaccine
true that's number one and what did
trump do to force us to do illegally
because i don't think he's ever forced
me to do anything illegally and wouldn't
joe be more of a jim jones since he is
forcing people to come over illegally
those are my two questions if we're a
bunch of occult followers then shouldn't
we all have the vaccine
no true that is true
we love this country and we love the
founding of this country
and we especially love freedom americans
love
their freedom uh our grandfathers fought
and died for that world war
ii um there's a lot of people that that
have died
for the freedoms of this country and
when we
witness what
for all this purposes looks to be a a
really jacked up election with the
lights we've never seen before
i'm for truly it's just on the surface
it looks all jacked up it looks really
bad the propaganda leading up to it
the prediction from the left saying oh
it's gonna look like trump won but
in the middle of the night it's gonna it
and biden really will have it and i mean
they predicted it it was so beautiful
they predicted it and now we find out
how incoherent biden is i mean just just
the insanity of all that this is why
americans middle america those
that love this country are so furious
when we had a president with an
incredible economy
and incredible achievements getting
things done
that literally put both sides every
politician out there
put them to shame
with the lackluster in the the do
nothingness
the dc is donald trump shamed
every one of them with the amount of
work that he got done in four years
and we see that erased this is why we're
angry
we're not angry because we're drinking
trump's kool-aid that's not why we're
angry
we're angry because what we had
was was the opportunity to get america
back on track
now and that was it was erased i
i'll say this in regards to jim jones
too jim jones went out looking for
followers
jim jones went out looking for followers
he went out looking to build his
congregation
into something that would follow him
whatever he did
and however he did it that's not what
trump's
uh uh no they found this was right
they found him if you
and i i know i know some people can get
mad at me that are watching right now
and stuff like that but if you
if there is a cult like
mentality yeah then
it's not on trump it's on the people
yeah it's on the people themselves it's
not true
it's not trump because the people
queue oh yeah yeah which i still think
was an fbi person on the left
yeah that i mean though though
they did it
i think obama's people did it uh
obama's people did it i mean where they
where the people where the person in
church can't do no wrong
can't do no wrong at all dick they can't
see it
hillary clinton hillary clinton here
i'll tell you another one i think this
is genius
yes jeb says this in the chat i really
wish i would have thought of this your
real jim jones is feltchy if you think
about it
honest to god that is the truth is
obsessed with him whatever they say
that whatever he says the left does if
he would say take the kool-aid they
would
line up and take the kool-aid wouldn't
they well they did they didn't take the
coolant right that's what yeah he's the
real jim jones
mm-hmm well 900 people died on the
chimney
they have these stickers they have a
felt listen they have a felt
though they have a fouchy algae pouchy
the left created it's called the fauchy
algae palchi
and you put your vaccine card in it and
people are obsessed with it you want to
talk jim jones kool-aid
you should see the left walking around
with their fouchy algae pouches
it is insane he's got he's got a a
larger death toll too
than jim jones by times 10.
easily they're saying it's over 10
000 the cdc is reporting over 10 000
well if that's the case then there are
you you got to go back there are a whole
lot of people that
put his his ideas
into place they have to be called out
too
i mean fauci fauci wasn't a legislator
they didn't have to listen to him no but
they did
glorified leah
talk to me though the legislators are
the ones that
i mean and and now look at them they're
they're talking about putting people
back down in lockdown
right i mean the the people that are
elected
are doing this yeah i found you gave me
the idea
but uh
are these legends days that stupid that
they just go with one person
yes i think so i think so right i think
so
so yes and here's a good example you'd
have to blame the legislators
more than fought you because fauci is an
elected he can't make law
i'll blame 50 50. i'm thinking
but here's the thing france you're not
allowed to get into gyms or restaurants
without a vaccine passport
or proof that you already have the virus
so as long as you can show that you have
antibodies you can get in we're not
doing that over here
new york just past the law that you
can't get into gyms
and restaurants without your without
your back proof of vaccine
they're not acknowledging natural
immunity in antibodies but francis
that's how stupid our leaders are
ah there you go um
that was my whole point i had to prove
your point which was yes i agree they're
stupid
but think about it you you you talk
about how
europe is like six weeks ahead on yes
they're about six weeks ahead of us on
this virus so wherever they are we'll be
in six weeks
so do you think we copy them a little
bit then we absolutely copy them we copy
them
and do exactly what we try to copy them
in an american way
if that makes sense we should have
copied should have copied sweden
yes sweden's that like hurt immunity
that's why they didn't wear masks
shut copied sweaty all got to hurt
immunity yeah no lockdowns
no man was higher but they got to hurt
immunity
or maybelline maybe china
remember or maybe we copied china you
remember china
locked down their whole city
or a whole lot of those big cities over
there before we ever even thought about
locking down anything remember
yeah but i think china always locks down
all right
i think that's their communist country
they're on perpetual lockdown yeah
they're just always on mental lockdown
they're locked out
as soon as they're born when they build
the three gorgeous damn
they dislocated millions and millions of
people by bayonet
told them you better get up the hill
we're flooding this place
thousands and thousands of years worth
of churches and relics
and history completely wiped out in
china because they wanted energy and
they wanted to damn
see uh even the ccp has come out and
said that uh
australia is so draconian that it's not
even funny what's going on
right i mean that's the ccp saying that
about it is that
how bad is that when you're like uh you
know what
was it when you're in the band guns and
roses and
a guy named slash says your drug habits
out of hand
how bad
[Laughter]
i got word last night that pete that uh
the police over in australia were
knocking on people's doors to see if you
had your friends over
and there's video on the tick tocks
currently yes we have
one pop fan a big we have a lot of
people that watch in australia but one
of our top fans lindsay i did not see
her on today
and that worries me like i wonder like
they said it's getting so bad that
they've cut out all the news
except for like that one mainstream news
and even like i said china's going dude
that's too much that's too much
people are getting pulled over and being
told that they're taking them to the
hospital
right now and they're fighting because
i'm not speaking right now
i don't want the hospital no no no make
this easy on yourself
get in the car and the guys i know
you're making it hard
i'm making it easy i won't go home i
said no
sorry cbd lion people
cbd line dot com forward slash wings
take a break
slumber berry um gummies uh
uh um the lotion
also uh the the tinctures
we asked you to check out these things
um a couple well
we have used their products we continued
to use their products uh wait what is
this
you know comes live right now talking
about this
is he really yeah that's why i thought
you said i don't have it so i was
sending it to you but como
is live i just sent it to you uh if we
wanna watch
well no i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
allow y'all to watch that we have to get
ready to get out of here
but uh right right uh but
again ladies and gentlemen cbdline.com
forward slash wayne dupree we all
have these these awesome um products
um leah has brian has them let them
let them know which ones i'll tell you
the lotion's my favorite it's full
spectrum there's a thousand milligrams
of cbd in the whole entire
bottle you get 10 milligrams per pump i
use two pumps it's paraben free
not tested on animal animals cd cbd
infused
and it works on my knee uh and it kept
it keeps the pain away
i've been pain-free now for over like
five months
and this has been going on for five
years doctors couldn't figure it out
i'll tell you i'm not putting too much
trust into doctors anymore i'm going
natural
and that's the truth cbd line
brian i mean i i'm seeing here
is clinically proven and uh
it's 100 legal way to treat chronic
chronic pain arthritis inflammation
diabetes ptsd uh
anxiety sleep disorder dementia and so
much more maybe
maybe biden needs to check that out he
needs to just drink the whole bottle of
lotion
just just drink it maybe it'll happen no
but uh
speaking about holistic uh my wife i
mean she's still young she's in her 30s
my wife
has been diagnosed with rheumatoid
arthritis and the doctors say that she's
got to be on this medication for
the rest of her life and every three
months she has to come in and have her
kidneys and her liver checked
uh because the medications the side
effects of medication
uh liver failure and kidney failure and
uh that doesn't make any sense to me why
you would do that so
her and i have always been open to
alternative
uh medicines in the past and she's
delved into a
deep long and and hard for sure and the
lotion
the cbd line is part of
that that she is doing uh this is
something that you
absolutely have to check out there's no
question about it and
there was a a thing that came on lately
about about bayer about aspirin
his stuff's no good for you it really is
not good
it's not healthy at all so one of our
good uh
listeners avid listeners in the chat
just said that como's denying it
yeah yeah i mean it's not crazy there's
no way that he would come out
yeah that yeah i did all that yeah
that's true
into the lotion on my knees this is the
first time i ever heard from bonnie
bonnie says she loves it loves the
patches and always use my code word
wayne well thanks bonnie
first time hearing from you this is
cromwell uh
yeah i did it and i'm just getting
started
i did not have sexual relations with
that woman
[Music]
no you didn't
come get me he said he's lonely
he said he's a lonely man he wants to
know where your piercings are wayne
that's right
he said he's a lonely man wants to know
where your piercings are and your tattoo
if you're gonna give it to me
and and and and the only message you
know his daughter's 22. well that's kind
of sick because
his honor was 22 but he would go as
young as 22 as what he
told him something messed up with that
so sick
patreon.com forward slash
i'm just bad i'm just bad about doing
this because it's i mean
i don't want people to think that we're
begging but god darn it we need your
help i'm telling you we need your help
um i looked at the
number of uh those that
are uh helping it used to be at the 164.
now it's down to 135. and but
the the great thing about that is nobody
has deleted their pledges
it's just bad cards okay so it means you
need to check your card folks you really
do
i mean i had my card on patreon for
years and all of a sudden
somebody said hey brian what happened oh
man i forgot all about that sorry yeah
yeah i mean people i mean people people
aren't checking the car people aren't
deleting their pledges
it's just that their cards are expiring
and
you know and believe me we we um
we we had a snack we had a snag
and you know i'm not going too personal
on him but we had a snag
for a few months and we didn't tell
anybody
but we had a snag where
you know we we're still recovering right
now
this show is still recovering right now
and but
um you know maybe maybe one day we'll
talk about
that maybe uncensored maybe
yeah okay
hey just let you know breaking news
potential hijack of the ship
asphalt princess off the coast of the
united arab emirates uh with vessels
believed to have been seized and armed
individuals reported to be on board
that's breaking news though
damn barbary pirates
muslims are
patreon.com wd show
here's a quote from new governor como
quote i never touched anyone
inappropriately
i am 63 years old does that have to do
with it
dirty old man
[Music]
okay